hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is tim ferriss welcome to another
episode of the tim ferriss show
my guest today many of you will know the
name and those who don't will know much
more about him
shortly professor yuval noah harari
is a historian and best-selling author
who is considered one of the most
influential public intellectuals in the
world i know that's setting a high bar
but his popular books might ring a bell
sapiens a brief history of humankind
homo deus a brief history of tomorrow
and 21 lessons for the 21st century have
sold
27 and a half million copies roughly in
60 languages i'll let that sink in for
people
27.5 million copies that is a lot of
square footage
or that's a cubic cubic feet cubic
meters
they've been recommended by barack obama
chris evans bill gates and many others
he's also behind sapiens a graphic
history which we'll talk about a brand
new graphic novel series in
collaboration with comic
artists david van der meulen i think
co-writer
and daniel casanave the illustrator this
beautifully illustrated series is a
radical reworking of his book
sapiens subtitle a brief history of
humankind the series will be published
in four volumes
starting with volume one the birth of
humankind which is available now
his website y and harari h-a-r-a-r-i dot
com
you can find them on facebook twitter
instagram on twitter harare underscore
yuval we'll link to all the rest of them
at tim.blog podcasts
this episode is brought to you by peak
tea that's p-i-q-u-e
i have had so much tea in my life i've
been to
china i've lived in china in japan i've
done tea tours i drink a lot of
tea and 10 years plus of physical
experimentation and tracking has shown
me many things
chief among them that gut health is
critical to just about everything and
you'll see where
tea is going to tie into this it affects
immune function weight management mental
performance emotional health
you name it i've been drinking fermented
poo air tea
specifically pretty much every day for
years now
poo air tea delivers more polyphenols
and probiotics than you can shake a
stick at it's like providing the optimal
fertilizer to your microbiome
the problem with good poo air is that
it's hard to source it's hard to find
real poorer that hasn't been exposed to
pesticides and other nasties which is
super common that's why
peaks fermented pure tea crystals have
become my daily go-to it's so simple
they have so many benefits that i'm
going to get into and i first learned
about them
through my friends dr peter atia and
kevin rose peak
crystals are cold extracted using only
wild harvested leaves from 250 year old
tea trees
i often kick start my mornings with
their poor green tea their poor black
tea
and i alternate between the two the rich
earthy flavor of the
black specifically is amazing it's very
very it's like a
a delicious barnyard very peaty if you
like whiskey and stuff like that
they triple toxin screen all of their
products for heavy metals pesticides and
toxic mold contaminants commonly found
in tea
there's also zero prep or brewing
required
as the crystals dissolve in seconds so
you can just drop it into your hot tea
or i also make iced tea and that saves a
ton of time and hassle
so peak is offering 15 off their puertes
for the very first time exclusive
to you my listeners this is a sweet
offer simply visit
peaktee.com tim that's p-i-q-u-e-t-e-a
dot com forward slash tim this promotion
is only available
to listeners of this podcast that's peak
t
dot com forward slash tim the discount
is automatically applied when you use
that url
you also have a 30 day satisfaction
guarantee so your purchase is risk free
one more time check it out
peak t that's p i q u e t e a dot com
slash tim
this episode is brought to you by all
form if you've been listening to this
podcast for a while you've probably
heard me talk about helix
sleep and their mattresses which i've
been using since 2017. i have two of
them
upstairs from where i'm sitting at this
moment and now helix has gone beyond the
bedroom and started making
sofas they just launched a new company
called all form a-l-l-f-o-r-m and
they're making premium
customizable sofas and chairs shipped
right to your door at a fraction of the
cost of traditional stores
so i'm sitting in my living room right
now and it's entirely all form furniture
i've got
two chairs i've got an ottoman and i
have an l sectional
couch and i'll come back to that you can
pick your fabric
they're all spill stain and scratch
resistant the sofa color
the color of the legs the sofa size the
shape to make sure it's perfect for you
and your home
also all form arrives in just three to
seven days and you can assemble it all
yourself in a few minutes no tools
needed i was quite astonished by how
modular
and easy these things fit together kind
of like lego pieces they've got arm
chairs love seats all the way up to an
eight seat
sectional so there's something for
everyone you can also start small and
kind of build on top of it if you want
to get a smaller couch and then build
out on it which is actually in a way
what i did because i can turn
my l-sectional couch into a normal
straight couch and then with a separate
ottoman
in a matter of about 60 seconds it's
pretty rad so
i mentioned i have all these different
things in this room i use the natural
leg finish which is their lightest color
and i dig it i mean i've been using
these things hours and hours and hours
every single day so i am using
what i am sharing with you guys and if
getting a sofa without trying it in
store sounds risky you don't need to
worry all form sofas are delivered
directly to your home with fast free
shipping and you get 100 days to decide
if you want to keep it
that's more than three months and if you
don't love it they'll pick it up for
free and give you a full refund
your sofa frame also has a forever
warranty that's literally
forever so check it out take a look
they've got all sorts of cool stuff
to choose from i was skeptical and it
actually worked it worked
much better than i could have imagined
and i'm very very happy so
to find your perfect sofa check out
allform.com
tim that's a-l-l-f-o-r-m-com
tim all form is offering 20 off all
orders to you my dear listeners at
allform.com
tim make sure to use the code tim at
checkout
that's allforum.com tim and use code tim
at checkout at this altitude i can run
flat out for a half mile before my hands
start to shake
can i answer your personal question now
i'm a cybernetic organism living tissue
over metal endoscopy
you've all so nice to finally see you
it's good to be here thank you for
inviting me
so we're going to start in a unusual
place perhaps okay and that is
with correcting my pronunciation on a
word m m-o-s-h-a-v
how do you pronounce that and what does
it mean oh
that's actually a kind of mistake on
wikipedia it's a mushaf
now it's some it somehow got around that
i live in
a moshov which is some kind of socialist
collective
community less radical than the kibbutz
but
one of the experiments of socialists in
israel like decades ago
and it's just not true i mean i live in
a kind of middle class suburb
of tel aviv so this is an example
for those listening of something that
some people call the wikipedia echo
effect because i i
tried to correct it so many times and
it's just i i gave up it's it's it's
stronger than right
so at some point it got into wikipedia
then it ended up in the guardian
then other people cite the guardian and
it just will not go away so it just
keeps coming back
so let's go to something that i think is
more of a first-hand report
and it's it's a paragraph from your
wonderful
profile i should say answers to
questions in tribe of mentors which is
my last book from a few years ago
and here's the paragraph i'd like to
read and then we'll explore it
since the first course in 2000 i began
practicing vipassana for two hours every
day
and each year i take a long meditation
retreat for a month or two it's not an
escape from reality it's getting in
touch with reality
at least for two hours a day i actually
observe reality as it is
while for the other 22 hours i get
overwhelmed by emails and tweets and
funny cat videos
without the focus and clarity provided
by this practice i could not have
written sapiens and homo deus
so the missing piece here is the first
course would you be open to describing
how you ended up going to your first
vipassana
experience um yeah i mean i was
doing my phd at oxford at the time about
medieval military history and
i was also looking for the meaning of
life and reading lots of philosophy
books
and thinking a lot and then nothing
really clicked
and the friend nagged me for about a
year to
try a meditation retreat instead of
reading all these books
and finally i gave up and said okay i'll
i'll try i'll see how it is
and it was really fascinating because
you know the the very first evening the
instructions that i was given by the
meditation teacher was very very simple
instructions i mean i guess many people
heard them
that you just focus your entire you sit
down you close your eyes
and you just focus your entire attention
on your nostrils on your nose
and you just feel try to feel
whether your breath is coming in or
whether your breath is going
out sounds like the simplest thing in
the world it's not even a breathing
exercise like you don't need to control
the breath just to
just let it be what it is and just feel
what it does
and i couldn't do it for more than 10
seconds like most people
that you know for 10 seconds i would be
focusing on my nostrils on my breath
and after 10 seconds my mind would run
somewhere like to some memory
some story some something i forgot to do
something that happened years ago and i
would roll in that for
for minutes before realizing that hey i
i'm missing my breath and come back
and this was an extremely humiliating
and important experience
because it made me realize for the first
time in my life that i have almost no
control over my mind
that you know i was doing my phd at
oxford i thought it was i was a very
intelligent
person very smart and you know my mind
is my my tool
and i have absolutely no control over it
i give it this very very simple task
and it can't do it and also you realize
how overwhelming the stories that the
mind produced
are and over time this was not on the
first night but gradually over time
it made me realize that you know if you
can't
focus on the simple reality of your
breath coming in and out of
your nostrils without being overwhelmed
by some
story generated in your mind then how
can you hope to understand
i don't know the financial system of the
world the geopolitical system
what's happening in israel in the middle
east
much much bigger things if you can't do
that
i mean no matter what i try to do
these stories generated by the by my own
mind
get between me and reality and most of
my life
i just spend on these stories
so it was ever since then it's one of my
main practices
in in life is how do you avoid
being overwhelmed by the stories that
your mind generates
why did your friend nag you for a year
was this a friend who was nagging
everybody to go
to a class and the teacher as i
understand it maybe it was in video
or or maybe in person s n goeink i
didn't know the lifespan
did they nag you because there's
something about you that told them you
would benefit in particular
or was it a general nagging i think i
mean i think this guy was nagging
everybody
in a good way i'm still good friends
with him
i i think he because i was really
looking hard to understand
life to understand what's happening here
then he thought i would be a good
candidate and then he was absolutely
right
now vipassana clicks for some people it
doesn't click for others some people
gravitate to
transcendental meditation and repeating
a mantra other people
might find a different type of
mindfulness practice but it clicked for
you
what did the before and after look like
if we let's just say go back to that
point in time your first
experience and then we flash forward six
months what had changed
six months later or or how did your
perception of the world change
some things changed dramatically most
things didn't
i mean you have this kind of false
enlightenment experience
that you think you realize something
very deep and now everything is going to
change
and over time you realize that the deep
patterns
of yourself of your own mind are much
much stronger
than one course of meditation
or practice of six months and it's a
it's a very long way
and again for some people it doesn't
click at all i mean when i came out of
my first course i thought oh that's easy
i mean every
you can set anybody there it will have
the same effect later on i realize it's
it's
it doesn't work like that different
things work for different people
over time they're changing on so many
levels i'm not sure
which of these levels is most
interesting to you or to our listeners
so i can talk on on several of them you
know everything from simple
simple kind of peace of mind and better
mental health to a
big change in my
working methods in my professional life
i don't think as
i wrote in this that passage you read i
don't think i could have written
sapiens or homo deus or any of these
other books
without the practice of meditation
because
you need a tremendous amount of focus to
do something like that
and you need to be able to see through
the
mass of details and you know you try to
summarize the whole of human history in
500 pages
the most important button
on the keyboard is delete
um that's the big thing i mean what i
mean are so many important things
what is really important that's the big
question
and i don't think i could have done it
without the kind of
sharp focus that the meditation gives
so many people have heard of sapience
certainly there was a point
in silicon valley when it first came out
and
nearly all of my friends seemed to be
reading this same book
and i think there's a sort of
revisionist
grand delusion among many readers that
sapiens
came out and then like the snap of the
fingers
20 million copies or however many
millions of copies were sold worldwide
in 60 languages
now that doesn't seem to to match the
story exactly
what was the title of the original
english version
of sapience and how many copies did it
sell
yeah it was a long story i mean the
original english version was titled
from animals into gods and it sold
it was a self-publication on amazon and
it sold
something like 2 000 copies they now go
for i don't know thousands of dollars or
something
because there are rare collector items
but yeah it was a it was a long way
it was a long way and you brought in
then at at that point a number of
professionals i believe maybe it was
your your husband who found yeah i mean
literary agent
that was the main thing i mean i have
i'm i think i'm quite a good writer but
i have very little skills
in terms of publication negotiations or
anything to do with the business side of
life
and i tried for some time for maybe a
year or two to find a publisher by
myself and it was a complete failure
and then my husband came in and he has
much much better business skills than i
do and he
like immediately fired the agent that we
were working with at the time
and kind of let's go back to zero
and he was the one that found uh
the best literary agent in israel
deborah harris and she
opened a lot of doors for us and we
worked on it for i think we kind of
we did the translation again in several
several because originally it was in
hebrew
and several rounds of editing and uh
eventually something like
three years or more than three years
after the hebrew version
the real english version came out in
2014
what were the biggest changes that were
made aside from the title i'd be curious
to hear the story of sapiens the title
itself but what were some of the
changes that were made in the editing
process
before the grand debut of the new
version if anything
i don't know if it was just fine-tuning
tuning nothing major changed i mean the
all the major themes and ideas were
already there in the hebrew
version uh we just really
redo the translation and edit it
and i mean shortening here and there if
a few things but
but there was no major revision to the
content
it was mainly issues of style
and the entire kind of uh business
approach of
who to work with and how and you
correct me if i'm wrong because you
never know what you read on the internet
the degree of uh veracity but
that it was based on lectures you had
given
previously yeah is that true that's
that's correct i i gave like
uh for five six years previously i was
giving a course at the hebrew university
which was basically introduction to the
history of the world
and at some point uh after working on it
for a couple of years
i began handing out my notes to the
students because i wanted them to focus
on what i was saying and be part of the
discussion instead of just
scribbling down whatever i say so i told
them forget it i mean you don't need to
write anything i'll give you my
notes and and then the notes started
circulating not only among the students
of the class
but also other students at the
university and this kind of gave me the
idea that well maybe there is a larger
audience for this
and i began working on turning these
lecture notes
into into a book again it was a long way
but a lot of the major ideas were there
in the in the lecture notes
and i wanted to hear more about this
because
i've seen in some books
that i've quite enjoyed like zero to one
by peter thiel and his his co-writer
also came from lecture notes originally
at stanford
yeah it's a good method because the
students take no [ __ ]
um you know when you write when you
write a book and it's only you
and the screen and the computer the
computer suffers everything
whatever you write the computer is fine
with it it's too long it's
it's incomprehensible it's boring the
computer doesn't care
but the students give you immediate
feedback i mean if you stand in class
and you
and you talk and you see that the
students have lost interest
then that's a sign or they just don't
understand what you're saying
and the great thing about this course it
wasn't really an introduction to
first-year students
and and israeli students and you know if
if it was i don't know in oxford then
maybe it wouldn't work
but israeli students they tell you
exactly what they think about you
and what you say so i got immediate
feedback about everything
and maybe the most important feedback is
that and i was trying to explain the
really basic concepts
of human history what is religion what
is money
what is capitalism and you need
you know when you talk with professors
or doctors
you can talk in a very very complicated
way
so nobody realizes including yourself
that you don't really know what you're
talking about
but with first-year students you have to
use very simple language
and that's a big challenge the simpler
the language
the bigger the challenge it really shows
you and your listeners whether you know
what you're talking about or not
you can't hide behind professional
jargon
and very complicated uh
i don't know language and
so so it was uh it forced me like i was
trying to explain what is money
and i had to go back again and again to
to the to the core ideas and to the
lecture notes and ask
do i really understand what i'm talking
about if i really understand
i should be able to make it simpler i
should be able
to give a straightforward example it
makes me
think quite a bit about uh richard
feynman the physicist who was
very very esteemed teacher and felt very
similarly
that that professionals could hide
behind labels right pointing at the bird
and
knowing the name is very different from
understanding the bird
and if you have to describe it in simple
terms it's a real
challenge of of competence and clarity
as a teacher you mentioned the term
suffering and i
again want you to fact check me but it
seems to me in doing homework and
reading your work that
you are very attuned to suffering
whether that is in the animal world
whether that is in the human experience
whether that is in your own experience
say with the endless cloudy days in
oxford at one point could you speak to
how you developed that sensitivity if if
i'm not
imposing that on you uh because i mean
you i'm looking behind you right now and
people might not be watching this video
but you have some calligraphy behind you
which
is uh i believe it's foshin which is
like buddhist
heart or buddhist mind somebody gave
you a present and they hang out there
right yeah it's beautiful it's beautiful
so that's what
that's what it says okay and suffering
and the concept of suffering is is also
central to
a lot of buddhist thought yeah could you
speak to
how you think about suffering or why
that is
is something that you're so cognizant of
yeah i realized both
in my personal life and in my work as a
historian
that this is the big question i mean the
big question is not
the meaning of life and the big question
is not
how you satisfy some god or how you
achieve this or that goal
the the big question is how you liberate
yourself and others from suffering and
this is also i think the main
theme of human history is
most historians are focused on the
question of power
if you take most history books and also
most economic books and and so forth
they are about power they are not just
you know a guide to how to get power
but about them the history of power
conflicts about power between two kings
between two kingdoms between two gods
between two religions between two
classes
these are most history books are about
that and
it's an important part but it's it's not
the bottom line i think the bottom line
okay
what does all this mean in term of
happiness and suffering
so okay so the roman empire rose to
power did it actually make humans
happier did it make them more miserable
if it had no noticeable effect on say
average
happiness in the world what does it
matter whether they want or lost
and in my work i try to always keep
both of these perspectives at the same
time
the perspective of of of power and of
suffering
especially because you know humans are
very very good as a species not all
humans but as a species
we are very good in acquiring more power
but we are not good at all in
translating power into happiness
and for me the big paradox of history is
that
it's obvious we are thousands of times
more powerful
than people in the stone age but it's
not clear
whether we are at all happier than they
were
maybe we are happier a bit but not
thousands of times more happier
so something is wrong you know it's like
a car which you know you you press the
fuel
pedal with all your strength but your
gear is in neutral
i mean we have so much power and it
doesn't move anywhere
and it's also often the case in your
personal life
that you can achieve so much and then
you know you look inside and you ask
am i actually happier than i was 10
years ago or 20 years ago and maybe not
and one of the things i also realized
personally and you know collectively as
a historian is that we just don't
understand suffering very well
one of the main problems is that people
think
that with regard to suffering
it's obvious what suffering is
the big problem is how to make it
how to make it disappear i know that i
don't know pain is suffering
or i don't have enough money that's
that's the cause of my suffering
so now let's focus on on getting more
money or getting a medicine
and the mistake is that you don't really
understand
the deep causes and mechanisms of
suffering you see just part of it yeah
obviously pain is suffering that's true
but there is much more to it and if we
spend a little more time
on understanding the deep mechanisms
of misery and dissatisfaction in life
then we can act far more effectively
in in trying to alleviate it can you
speak to the
the test of suffering to determine
what entities are real and what are not
what illusion
and what are not i mean i shouldn't say
illusion maybe abstractions
the main way that humans gain power is
through collective cooperation
as individuals we are not particularly
powerful animals
in a match between the human and
chimpanzee the chimpanzee will easily
win
the big advantage of humans we can
cooperate basically in unlimited numbers
thousands millions today even billions
cooperate together
chimpanzees can't cooperate more than
say 50 or 100
that's about the limit and then you know
what enables us to cooperate in very
large numbers
these are this is our ability to invent
and believe in fictional stories and
fictional entities
all the big heroes of history almost all
of them are fictional entities that
exist only in our imagination
only in the stories that we create
nations gods money
corporations states the only place
they exist is in the stories that we
invent
and tell as they are they are not
physical or biological realities
again the united states or israel the
only place it exists is in the story
that millions of people believe and it's
the same with money it has you know
money has absolutely no objective
value but as long as millions of people
believe in the story about the dollar or
the story about the euro
it works now when you say that
sometimes people go to the other extreme
and think
that what you're saying is that nothing
is real
that the entire world is just one big
illusion
but that's not the case i mean there is
still
reality there are still chimpanzees and
elephants and humans
and there is a very very simple test
to know whether the hero of the story
that you are telling
is a real entity or a fictional entity
invented by humans and existing only in
their imagination
and that is the test of suffering that a
human being can suffer
a cow can suffer an elephant can suffer
but a nation can't if a nation loses a
war
it doesn't suffer it has no mind it
can't feel
pain or sadness or fear
the soldiers who are fighting for the
nation the citizens in that nation now
being conquered by some other nations
they can suffer a lot of things
but the nations can't suffer it should
be obvious
and it's the same as corporations even
if the corporation loses a billion
dollar
it doesn't suffer it if it goes bankrupt
it doesn't suffer
because it again it has no mind can't
feel pain can't feel anything
so it's you know it's a very very simple
test that we should remind ourselves
from time to time what is
real in the world and what are these
fictional stories now i'm not against
the stories we need them
they are the basis for cooperation but
we should always remember
we created them as tools to serve
us we shouldn't be enslaved by them
if a story enables people to cooperate
well
and thereby improve their lives that's
wonderful
but once you forget it's just a story
and you begin
entire wars just in order to protect to
defend the owner of the nation
or to increase the profits of the
corporation
something went wrong
just a quick thanks to one of our
sponsors and we'll be right back to the
show
this episode is brought to you by
linkedin jobs the colorful days of fall
are now upon us are your small
businesses needs evolving changing with
the times
certainly true for me and my team and
despite the current uncertainty in the
world having the right people
on your team can wrap you in feelings of
security and peace of mind
like a warm blanket it's never been more
important to find and hire the right
people
linkedin has an active community of
professionals more than 690 million
members worldwide
and when your business is ready to make
that next hire linkedin jobs can help
you find the right person quickly by
matching your role with qualified
candidates
getting started is easier than ever with
new features to help you find qualified
candidates
quickly manage job posts and contact
candidates from one simple view on
linkedin.com's
familiar website it's super easy
identify strong candidates with their
efficient rating system
to easily get your job in front of more
qualified professionals and now you can
also do
all of this from your mobile device so
when your business is ready to make that
next hire or if you just want to check
it out
find the right person faster with
linkedin jobs you can pay what you want
and get the first
fifty dollars off just visit
linkedin.com
tim all caps tim again that's
linkedin.com
tim to get 50 off of your first job post
terms and conditions apply
what is the story if there is one or
stories that you have
around money yourself i was reading the
new yorker profile
not from not too long ago and you
probably know the paragraph that i might
be thinking about where you and your
husband might relate to money
differently what are the stories that
that you have
for yourself in your life money but in
essence money is just trust
it's the most successful and universal
system of mutual trust
that humans ever came up with and
therefore i don't think it's bad
you know it's very common for historians
and philosophers and
people like that oh manny it's the
source of all evil in the world
i don't think so it sometimes it causes
a lot of bad things
but in itself it's a wonderful thing
it's just a system of mutual trust
that you know fifty thousand years ago
to trust somebody
you need to know them personally you
need to know their
personality what they did in the past
they like you they don't like you
and that makes it very very hard to
cooperate in large numbers because you
can't know a lot of people personally
and it also makes it particularly hard
to cooperate with
strangers and foreigners that you don't
know
now you look at today i can go to a
supermarket
and a complete stranger that i never met
in my life
would give me food that i can actually
eat
which was grown by a couple of other
people on the other side of the world
and was transported from that field or
plantation to the supermarket by a bunch
of other people none of us knows
so how do we cooperate so effectively
how do we trust each other
um money makes it possible and
money is really it's just trust you know
in the beginning money
was uh and because people didn't have a
lot of trust
then money had to be made from something
with an objective value
which doesn't depend just on on human
belief so the first money that we know
about was simply grain
you paid for things with grain and grain
you know you can eat them if nothing
works
but gradually people that the trust
increased and today most money in the
world
is just digital data being passed
between computers
most money is not even bank notes and
coins it's i don't know like five
percent or something of the of the money
is is physical money most of it is just
digital
when during this crisis in the recent
year
uh governments and banks in the u.s in
europe elsewhere
created trillions of dollars they didn't
even bother to print the money you just
have some
official in some bank goes into the
computer adds a zero somewhere
you have a trillion new dollars emerging
out of nothing
and it works i mean it works because
people have so much
trust in the banks in the governments
not only of their own country that's the
amazing thing
i mean you'd have thought well you can
only use the money of your government no
you think about even i don't know
islamic fundamentalist isis
they hated america they hated american
politics american culture
american religion but they had nothing
against american dollars
when they conquered i don't know mosul
and enter the banks they didn't burn the
dollars that were there they took them
they used them
so that's amazing that you can have such
a level of
trust even between complete enemies
and in my personal life um therefore i
don't have a
negative attitude towards money
um i think for me i i'm also i i'm not
chasing it a lot
but for me the best thing about money is
not to think about it
i'm now much wealthier than i was 10
years ago
you know just a young professor back
then not that i was ever poor
but i'm not much more wealthier and the
the thing i like most about my wealth
today
is that i simply don't have to think
about money i go to the supermarket
and i i don't know in israel pineapples
are very expensive
so if i wanted pineapple i just i i
don't even look
at how much it costs i just oh i want
the pineapple okay let's take it
you've mentioned the alleviating of
suffering
and getting a better understanding first
of defining the problem as opposed to
just
rushing to solutions and getting a
better understanding of suffering
are there ways in which your life in
contrast to say not thinking about money
has been complicated or made harder to
navigate with the tremendous success
of sapiens and becoming more publicly
visible
in other words was it as as just an
example
easier to find sort of tranquility
and connection with bodily sensations
as a way to integrate yourself back at
oxford compared to today
no but i have 20 years of experience now
in doing that
so i don't know maybe if i remained an
anonymous professor of medieval history
it i would have much deeper experiences
of meditation today maybe not
it's impossible to know i still have
time
you know i'm i'm not so busy i have now
a large team like
again thanks to my husband to kind of
set it up
we now have a team of 15 people working
for us
so i get something like i don't know 15
20 emails a day that's it
and like this conversation i didn't have
to do anything
i just had to come like two minutes
before it started
and just put like plug myself in and
that's it somebody organized everything
so um i'm not extremely busy
i i still have two hours every day to
meditate
i still go every year for a long retreat
of say
30 days or 40 or 60 days something like
that
um yeah i mean i i think a lot
there are a lot of things to think um
but i thought a lot even before that
so i mean the the content of my thoughts
changed but i don't think the intensity
changed
one of the things i realized for now
being this famous public intellectual
and meeting all these
famous people and leaders is that
everybody is is basically the same
when you are prime minister or president
of a superpower
you can't be more uh
worried than when you run a small
business it's impossible it's you know
it's the same brain it's the same mind
so if you have a small shop and you're
the only worker maybe
and it's now corona time and and
you have to shut it down and you have to
pay uh
your remote gauge and whatever you worry
about it all day
it's basically the same with a prime
minister or president
that worries about the economic crisis
of a war
it's yeah of course objectively they
have to be much more worried but they
can't
they have the same brain that you have
so it really depends
on you know maybe they are even far less
worried than you are
if you are an extremely neurotic person
i don't know if woody allen had a small
shop and i think
he would be much more worried about his
shop
than certain presidents and prime
ministers today in the world are worried
about their countries
[Laughter]
so i read uh i've read a quote from you
this is in the new york times
if if i was a superpower my superpower
would be detachment
uh feel free to correct that if need be
but
assuming there's some grain of truth to
that could you expand on that please
yeah i think it is true that i
i can keep a kind of distance
from situations
from development in in my personal life
or in in world history and
even though i have my opinions and on my
preferences
i have a certain ability to to keep a
distance and say
look at things from from different
angles and
um also it makes me very skeptical about
my own positions
but maybe maybe i just don't know maybe
i'm wrong about it
um it could have been you know
debilitating that i can't
like how can you write the history of
the world if you're not sure about what
you're saying
but actually i find it i i just don't
take myself
a hundred percent seriously so okay so
maybe i'll write something
and it's nonsense so okay uh
that's when i wrote sapiens initially i
had no idea what would be a big success
so i was kind of i had this defense that
i thought
nobody's going to read it like maybe my
students at university would read it
and maybe a couple of other people but
that's it so you know i can write what i
want basically
and later on when i became very
successful it was the other way around
then that you know it doesn't matter
anymore
that if i'm if if i write something and
it's not
um and i'm not 100
sure about it then
i can take the hit then okay so people
will find out that i wrote
something wrong and and that's fine
that's part of the business i mean if
you really want to
uh write these kinds of big books
you have to accept to some extent
that you will make mistakes and that um
you will not get everything right if you
want if you're a perfectionist
then it's better to write the history of
kind of one battle in the middle ages
that then you're on safer grounds this
is going to seem like a
strange question perhaps and if it goes
nowhere that's totally fine but i'm
curious
what do your close friends come to you
for when it comes to advice like what
type of advice
do your friends come to you for is there
any any pattern to it
or any particular standout it depends on
the friends i think i have
a core of very good friends that go with
me for years
i mean from long before i i think that
since i became kind of famous
i made maybe just one or two new good
friends
almost all my good friends are with me
from years back and i have different
relationships with each of them it's
like
each one of them holds a different part
of my inner world
or of my life and i hold different parts
of
the world so you know they don't come
from it to me for advice about history
that's for sure
maybe they'll ask me well what do you
think will happen in the u.s elections
and i said i don't know
but i mean some if something really big
happens i don't know when they uh
during the the height of the of the
terrorist wave in the world
so they would come and at least some of
them and i would say
look for a big historical perspective
this is not so important
you know every person that dies in a
terrorist attack is the entire world
destroyed
but looking at the big picture from the
history of the world this is a very
small affair
i mean i can explain to you why
terrorism gets
so much attention it's basically theater
these people are experts in theater not
in war
and they are very good at it so they get
so much attention
but you don't need to worry that the
terrorists will take over the world
it's not going to happen uh most of the
things you know it's like somebody's
breaking up with their boyfriend
girlfriend
somebody is just having a lousy day at
work and
the the usual things the usual stuff
what would they say your superpower is
if if you said it's detachment
which we could dig further into but is
are there any other observations
that they would have if if we gave all
of your closest friends
two drinks and we said okay you've all
superpower what is it what might they
say first they will say different things
because they know different angles of me
right
i think some of them will say i suppose
that i'm a good listener
partly because i talk so much during my
with my
my work that like when i meet these
friends i like to be quiet and just
let somebody else do the talking for a
while which is a very good thing
because very very often when people come
to you for help they just want you to
listen
they don't want you to solve their
problems they don't
you know it often happens that comes
somebody comes you know with a problem
and you don't have patience for them so
you think what is the fastest way to get
rid of them to end this
phone call i'll find the solution of
their problem then they'll go away
and this really is the last thing they
want they really just want to complain
and for somebody to listen to them and
i'm quite good at it
right you spend all your words during
the day and then you can
you you have the space to listen uh yes
how do you relate to happiness yeah i
usually prefer to talk about suffering
or misery
uh because happiness is is far more
difficult to nail down
i mean when you're miserable you know it
when you're happy when you think you're
happy
you're quite often just deluding
yourself
it's not so easy to really understand
what's happening there you know it
really goes down to the level of the
body
this is something that i i know for
meditation when you have a pain
somewhere in your body it acts like a
magnet
they just draws their attention there
there is no way you can miss it
and you try to to observe other things
and you can't it's just you and it gets
drawn back to the painful sensation in
the knee in the stomach wherever it is
but when you have pleasant sensations in
your body they have
usually the opposite effect they throw
you out
you kind of float a couple of feet above
the ground
i mean sometimes people come in
meditation and they say i never have any
pleasant sensations in the body
i just have pain and that's it's never
the case
what's true is that when you have
pleasant sensations
you don't notice them because the usual
effect
of feeling something very pleasant it
throws you out
you start kind of imagining hey what if
i win the lottery and i'll have a
million dollars i'll do that i'll do
that
and you you lose connection with what at
the time that you're having these
very pleasant thoughts you're having
very pleasant sensations in the body but
you don't notice it
and um it's it's i find it it's it's
harder to work
and to see what's actually happening
there
but it's i would it's even more
important
than kind of noticing and working with
with the painful sensations
i mean most in the end most of our i
would say
the the really difficult problems they
begin
with the pleasant sensations that
um you know we become so attached to
them
that the moment they are gone most of
the time people
don't have very painful experiences
most of the time if you are dissatisfied
it's because you are
missing or craving for some very
pleasant experience which is just not
there
and you're not willing to settle for the
kind of
ordinary boring thing that you do have
i want to rewind to your description of
your
current life compared to your just say
pre-fame life
which seems to be similar in many ways
you've been able to preserve
the space to do what you do best you
have this team
you have this this husband is very good
at saying no you have personal
assistants who are very good at saying
no
and to many people listening who have
achieved some modicum of success
i think they will listen with great envy
because
very often whether they are
artists whether they are business people
what made them successful
is often the first thing to get crowded
out by
the new attention and success that they
receive
aside from luck because perhaps there
was some
luck and chance involved in meeting the
person who then became your husband
were there any decisions or are there
any
decisions or frameworks or anything at
all that has helped you to
preserve the space that you have i think
a very important decision
was to keep the meditation first
that like when i plan my day when i plan
my year
it's the first thing i put in the
calendar is the meditation which reads
and everything else has to
find space around that and that was a
very
it was a conscious decision and a very
important decision that that really
worked
and in in a bit similar way also to
keep time for my old friends to keep
time for my family
and understanding that this is kind of a
marathon race
and not a sprint but okay something very
important happens the new book is coming
out there is a
there is a lot of important things so
okay so i can
i can change my routines for a while but
over the long run you have to keep
these kind of basic blocks intact
this was a very conscious decision in my
case
uh it worked also to kind of remember
what's really important for you in life
for me i think maybe you know on the
personal level
i really want to understand
life to understand the world what's
happening i noticed
quite early that most of kind of the
big events that i'm participating in
like conferences and and so forth
and the important people i meet they
don't really contribute much to that
they don't seem to understand their life
or have to have some particular insight
in the big conferences they never talk
about these things
you know they talk about the global
economy they talk about climate change
they talk about
they are important things but in on the
deeper level
of what's actually happening here it's
um
i won't get any answers from from there
you know it's i don't think it's a
coincidence that
you look at the whole span of human
history and almost
none of the important political leaders
of humankind
made a significant philosophical
contribution
to human thought you have a few
exceptions i don't know marcus aurelius
or something like that
but generally speaking you would have
thought
that from their vantage point
they see something that ordinary mortals
don't
they maybe they reach the top because
they have some very keen
insight into human nature and if they
have some kin inside
they keep it very very secret
[Laughter]
who are some of the people you respect
could be past or present
for really
seeing or seeking what is going on
on the deeper levels i i can tell you i
mean some of the names of
thinkers and writers that influenced me
great let's start there yeah so i mean
charles taylor the canadian philosopher
really influenced me
a lot his book the sources of the self
is i think one of the most important
books i read in life one of the most
difficult books also
i mean if people take this as a kind of
reading recommendation
they should be warned it's it's really
tough going
it's a very big book very dense but
if you make it it's really worth it oh
of course i was very influenced by
my meditation teacher essen goenka again
not
necessarily by any books he wrote or
just by
by the the guidance i mean i remember
sitting in my first week past and of
course and
and having this this guy really gets it
he really understands what's what's
happening uh
this was something quite surprising for
me
to see that some of my good friends have
some insight
into what's happening here
i i can give a list of of books that
influenced me
i'm not sure if this is kind of the
unanswered the question
but we are free free to meander this is
we don't have constraints one of the
problems i realized it's that
it's extremely difficult to share
the really deep insights you have about
life
that very often they are in a non-verbal
level and
in any case my impression is that
most of the inner world of most humans
is never shared
they never talk about it because they
don't even have the words
and don't have the audience i mean most
of what happens to you deep down
during the day your spouse probably
doesn't know your parents don't know
your children don't know your friends
don't know even you don't know
if you don't really make the effort
one of them qualities of great art
not just writing but different kinds of
art that it really
gives words that you know you
feel something for many maybe for years
and you have no idea how to communicate
it
and then you read a phone or you see a
tv
show and yes this is exactly what i'm
feeling and i never knew how to
communicate it
so that's why it's also very difficult
to kind of know
you meet somebody and you don't really
know
what's going on inside them and to what
extent they
understand or don't understand their
life or life in general so it's very
very hard to say
well you also underscore something that
i've thought about a lot recently which
is
it's quite unfair to expect other people
to understand you fully when you don't
understand yourself fully
on your own it's quite
quite an unfair expectation of people
sometimes
this is a basic expectations because
because we have trouble understanding
ourselves
we have this hope that somebody will
lend us a hand
and we have the experience at least most
of us if we came from
loving families that when you were kids
there were people there like our parents
who did exactly that for us
even on the most banner level that you
know a child is crying
and uh the mother would say well you're
just tired just go to sleep
and you you figure out well you should
know that you're tired but no
i mean it's amazing that sometimes
people are tired or hungry or whatever
and they don't know it and then somebody
who really understands and comes come to
simple just go to sleep
and in in my writing i engage a lot with
the issue of the future of ai and
surveillance
and i think one of the key
fantasies with ai in surveillance
is that um the algorithms will do that
for us
that will this well this ties into one
of the books that has had a big impact
on you if i remember correctly right i
mean the aldous huxley and
brave new world yeah brave the world i i
it really had really really deep impact
on me
um because i i think he really got it
and that he
the interesting thing about brave new
world it's kind of you know
it's on the surface it's a dystopia
but when you kind of ask yourself why
what's wrong with brave new world it's
very difficult to say it
to find out i mean everybody seems to be
satisfied
everybody seems to be happy there is a
system in place
that understands you very very deeply
and make sure that you'll never be in
great pain or never never
suffer any any great misery
and it's it's a very in in distance you
know 1984
like it's it's brother book 1984
it's a very simple book in this sense
that
1984 describes a terrible terrible
dystopia
the only question is how do we avoid
getting there
but bravely well do you read it and at
least for me
i kind of think okay so what's what's
really
wrong with it and it's not easy to
answer this question
yeah the the sort of uncanny feeling
that something is not quite right that
you can't put words to
it's very similar to the feeling of
something that is quite right that you
can't put words to that then gets
reflected in good art
it can go both ways yeah and a number of
the things that i read
in preparation for this from various
profiles there's one that said you
prefer television to novels there was
another that gave the example might have
been the same profile of you
swimming as part of your routine in the
summer and listening to non-fiction
books
via headsets but they're i guess they're
resonant they deal with the vibration of
the
yeah this is a really nice gadget i i
came across
and i i tried to listen through like
usual earplugs
and water would sit in somehow all the
time and
would ruin it and then finally i came
across this gadget that you can just put
it on your forehead
and some in some mysterious way it works
better
and you actually hear better than when
you put it in your ears
so yeah i would swim back and forth back
and forth listening to
i don't know i i listened to say to
shoshanna zubov's surveillance
capitalism
while swimming back and forth in my pool
with the with the dolphin headset for
the resonance that's amazing so i'll
it's a forehead headset perhaps do you
recall what type
it is by any chance i know this is
getting into the minutia
if not we can figure it out i can go and
look for it if it's very important
and it's just it's just in the in the
next room so like
it will take me a second if you want oh
yeah let's yeah sure let's let's grab it
why not okay
i don't want to say this is the most
important thing in the world but i'm
curious i'll take it
it'll take a minute
so uh it's a this is how it looks by the
way
oh wow all right so it's connected to
the
dorsal snorkel that goes across the
forehead so you don't have to rotate
yes and i don't have to pull this like
my put my
head back and forth all the time from
the water yeah it's by
finis duo finish finis
all right we'll we'll find it and put it
in the show notes thank you for grabbing
that
in those examples in these profiles
it seems like you are not consuming much
written fiction but brave new world is
fiction
yeah fast becoming reality and maybe
also like you said
philosophy disguised as science fiction
are there other fiction books that you
have found to have an impact on you or
your thinking or do you do you consume
much in terms of quite similar yeah it's
quite similar to brave new world i think
hitchhiker's guide to the galaxy
i also great i also list it as a
philosophy book
um you know i think that and it had an
impact on not just on on my thinking but
on my
on on how i write or work
that i'm not saying it is a kind of uh
i don't know metaphor or something that
these are they are philosophy books they
just are written
in a different way uh the and this is
one of the ideas that gave me the
inspiration to kind of turn
sapience into a graphic novel which we
might discuss later on if if we have the
time
that you can play with the form
i think that aldous huxley when he came
to write brave new world
he had these philosophical issues he
wanted to discuss
and maybe i'm inventing money maybe it
wasn't like this at all
but my impression is that he thought
well it will actually be
easier and more interesting and engaging
instead of
uh you know having these formal logical
arguments
and instead of having these thought
experiments which philosophers love so
much
why not have an entire book which is
one long thought experiment and
see where it takes me and i think that
the hitchhiker's guide to the galaxy
is basically something similar that it
explores a lot of deep philosophical
issues
but in a much more fun way
than your typical philosophy book i
could not agree more i
just literally a few weeks ago listened
to hitchhiker's guide to the galaxy
narrated by stephen fry who's an
incredible narrator
for the first time and
you're right that it has so many
what otherwise could be very sterile
thought experiments
and concepts yeah embedded into this
entertaining narrative and i remember
one line they're talking about the
i want to say he's the president of the
galaxy or something yes
that's what people brooks that's right
people brock's
and they they talk about how successful
he was
and how people have the mistaken notion
that the job of the president is to
wield power but that's not the job of
the president it's to distract
from those who are wielding power and
just these
short nuggets contain
so much to chew on and
it's it's really an effective way of
providing
people with footholds in a way yeah
toeholds
it's the same with tv like i think that
black mirror at least some of the
episodes in black mirror
are some of the best discussions that i
i've seen
of certain dangerous tendencies
in in current technology i mean some
episodes are just
fun uh i don't know like sanjani pero i
think it's a it's an extremely good
episode but it describes the reality
which is so far away from us
that it's it's not really relevant to
any of the discussions here
but you look at if you start nosedive
about and you know maybe the chinese got
the idea
for their social credit system from
nosedive
but it's such a powerful and important
episode
of you look at um how was it called
the one with the cartoon figure that
became president
that almost became a a mp
uh the the blue bear something and you
know this is before trump this was
before this whole wave and
they this was so prophetic it was really
amazing
when i watched it for the first time in
2013 i thought what were they talking
about
and then i watched it later like five
years later that these guys are just
geniuses
i mean how did they see it coming yeah
it's very it's
it's a real sweet spot of a near-term
or not-too-distant future kind of
technological extrapolation
i love black mirror i and i always
encourage people to watch at least three
episodes because
i would say maybe one out of three or
one out of four just completely miss
uh for me they don't kind of sort of
strike a chord so you have to
your sample size has to be a few
episodes and you'll usually strike on
something uh do you have any other
we are going to talk about sapient
graphic history because i have
a lot of questions about it before we
get there i have two
actually i'll stick with one question
before we get there and that is any
other
television series could be documentaries
also or movies
that you think are intelligent
examples of philosophy or thought
experiments in disguise
again going back to the usual suspects
of
science fiction i thought that hair was
a very intelligent
and you know low key exploration
of some of the potential of of ai i
don't like these movies
when the robots rebel and kill everybody
i mean this is such
it's implants the wrong fears
and it encourages the wrong discussions
i don't think that in the next 20 or 30
years
the robots are going to rebel and kill
everybody but there are other dangers
much more so i mean or less subtle
whether it's the job market
whether it's surveillance and what it
will do to politics
or whether it's you know changes in in
human relationships
and i thought that her was a very in in
this way a very intelligent
uh movie that avoided the usual traps
and it goes back exactly to what we were
discussing earlier that
we have a deep yearning that somebody
out there in the world
would really understand us like we go
about life and we hope that our parents
would understand
us our teachers our lovers our kids
somebody please understand me
and for many people it never happens and
to some extent somebody understands them
but there are many hidden corners within
themselves
that they are unable to communicate
and maybe they don't understand them
fully and there is nobody out there
that reaches out and and kind of engages
those corners in them
and there is now a technology on the
rise
which could fulfill that dream and this
is extremely attractive and extremely
frightening at the same time
and harry spot on i mean what happens
when there is an algorithm that
constantly observes you
not just what you do but also what's
happening inside your body
and really understands your personality
your moods your likes your dislikes
you know you come back home from work
and you're
grumpy and your husband doesn't notice
it but the computer does notice it
i mean and what kind of world is it what
kind of relationships
will there be when computers
and objects understands you
better than the people in your life
and that's a fascinating and frightening
uh question and i think a very realistic
question
we are very unlike the robots rebelling
and killing everybody
the moment that your smart refrigerator
knows you better than your husband
is not very far in the future
[Laughter]
and you know this is we we should be
talking more about that and i would like
to see
more movies more tv shows more science
fiction novels that explore
uh these kinds of questions yeah
if if you haven't read any of ted
chang's work c-h-i-a-n-g he has a he has
a
a compilation of short stories called
exhalation okay and
he has another collection of short
stories i think you would absolutely
love them
one of his short stories was turned into
i believe it was a rival
about the protagonist who's this female
linguist who decodes the the graphic
language of these aliens who
arrive on earth and it's about temporal
perception it's
these are really really really
incredible stories so ted
chang c-h-i-a-n-g-n exhalation i think i
think you'd enjoy it
let's talk about sapiens of graphic
history well before we get to that i
just want to say that the
word understand and the concept of
understanding is
also fraught with difficulties and i
think that that is
part of what ai will also demonstrate
that knowing quite a few people who work
on ai
what does it mean for let's just say a
computer or
a refrigerator to pass the turing test
so effectively
that you feel understood well it's not i
i don't believe they'll be conscious
i don't believe that we are near the
point when they will have consciousness
and if by understand you mean
the kind of inner feeling that we have
when we understand that that's not the
case
i think we are not near there but
understands
in the sense that able to predict our
behavior and response
right unconsciously in a way
which will be more appropriate than the
people around us
that's what what i mean by it yes it's a
weaker definitely i'm not thinking about
the conscious experience
of understanding it's about just
predicting
could be manipulating but most
importantly just
a kind of reacting to us
in a way that we will find appropriate
more appropriate in the way that you
know we will get so used
to having these computers and robots
that are very attuned to how we feel
that we might become even more irritated
with the humans
who don't feel who don't react who don't
understand how we feel and don't react
in in the right way and part of the
problem is that
so many people like everybody are often
self-centered
so i don't get what my husband is
feeling because i'm too focused on my
own my own feelings
one of the reasons that computers could
be better than humans
in this is that they don't have feelings
the refrigerator doesn't have any
expectations in life from you
he had no dreams no phantom nothing so
the refrigerator can be a hundred
percent focused on what you
feel it has no feelings of its own so it
can't be insulted can't be angry nothing
sounds like you have an episode of black
mirror to write
[Music]
but and to to that point on some level
we were talking about philosophy
disguised as fiction
or thought exercises embedded into say
black mirror in a way that
are not just fascinating but also
prophetic in some respects
sapien's a graphic history i want to
talk about this because
i actually have a long history with
graphic novels and comic books i wanted
to be a penciller a comic book penciller
for about 12 years
and used used to be an illustrator a
long time ago and then i lived in japan
in high school went to a japanese school
and
in japan unlike in the us there is a
long rich history
of comic books and graphic novels for
adults and also
comic books and graphic novels for
teaching difficult concepts
telling history and these are extended
expansive
collections of graphic novels and i've
seen how effective it is
because i i read some of these when i
was in japan on the history of judo and
other things and
i would not have consumed 500 pages of
pure text
certainly not in japanese and i think
it's an incredibly powerful
format how and why did you decide to
take sapiens and create
this piece of art but also an effective
vehicle for perhaps teaching in a
different way
actually the initiative didn't come from
me it came from david and danielle
the two artists who collaborated with me
on this project
they came up with the idea they brought
some initial suggestions
and i really liked it it connected to
something that i did want to do
for a long time which is to reach new
audiences
i see my main job today as
bringing science and history to more
people
people who wouldn't necessarily read a
traditional science book
even if it's popular science they still
won't read it like 500 pages of text
with footnotes it's it's
that they won't touch it but they might
connect
to a graphic novel and yes it is for
adults and teenagers i mean many people
in the west have the idea that comics
are for kids but no it's it's just a
different medium it's a different
language
it enables you to do i mean some things
you can't do
you need to you know cut down the text
but there are many things you can do
much
better in a graphic novel certainly to
show things
like you know the much of the graphic
novel is about the
life of hunter gatherers so you can just
show it in images instead of long
descriptions
an image is worth a thousand words in
many cases
it also enabled us to and for me it was
i know the most fun project i ever
worked on
because it was okay let's take all the
academic conventions of how you write
history and throw them aside
let's experiment so it's kind of a
series of experiments
in how to tell history
so you know one part about the evolution
of different human species the sempians
neanderthals
and so forth it's taught like a reality
tv show
that there are different competitions
between different human species
then you have an entire chapter about
the how humans
caused the extinction of
many of the large animals of the world
as they spread from africa over the
world
and this is told as a detective movie we
created this fictional detective
detective lopez like sherlock holmes or
agatha kind of a person and
she goes around the world and
investigates the worst serial killers in
history who
killed all these big animals and the the
invention of the first religions is told
according to the conventions of
superhero action movies so we created
this superhero superheroine doctor
fiction
who embodies the human ability to
invent fictional stories and mythologies
and it was really fun working with david
and daniel on that
and just saying well why not we can try
that we can do that
it's allowed it also forced
me and actually all of us to answer many
questions which we can
just ignore in the text
when you draw you have to draw specific
things
when you write you can write in
obstructions when you draw
you can't draw obstructions so if for
instance you talk about
the connection between homo sapiens and
neanderthals
and we now know that some sapiens and
neanderthals had sexual relations
and even had children because most of us
today
still carry some neanderthal genes in
our dna
now in a book you can just write that
sapiens had sex with neanderthals end of
story
but in a graphic novel if you want to
draw it you have to make some decisions
i mean who is the man and who is the
woman is it a neanderthal man with the
sapience woman or the other way around
and what about skin color what about
hair color hairstyle
all these questions you can't draw a
general human
it must have some skin color must have
some hair color
so we have to go back to the literature
the scientific
literature and investigate and sometimes
you find answers sometimes you don't
and then you have to take into account
all the ideological and political issues
of race and gender and so it's
it's a huge huge thing to engage with
all these
and i i found it that it's not like okay
let's just take sapiens and add some
illustrations
it's a completely fresh project how did
you problem solve
when there was a conflict or some
tension between the literature
and what might dictate a drawing
and the sort of political sensitivities
that exist
today how did you how did you think
about that or think through
those types of decisions we had a lot of
discussions
about these things and you know it was a
balancing act
you can't ignore science just for the
sake of being politically correct
on the other hand you have to be aware
of the political implications
of the choices you make i mean you can't
hide behind scientific objectivity
because there is no such thing as a
completely
objective narrative just choosing
what is the opening scene and what is
the ending scene
it doesn't come from reality it comes
from your
political ideological or religious
beliefs in reality the real reality
it has no beginning and end no
historical event
had a beginning and an end and no
historical event
had a focus you know it's even easier to
think about it in terms of movies
when you watch a movie let's say about
the second world war
so the camera is somewhere and something
is in the focus
of the of the shot something is on the
side and many things are
don't you don't see them at all now in
reality there is no camera
there is no camera hanging above planet
earth
the camera of history which points in a
particular direction
and this is the center of events and
this is the the sidelines
you know you can tell the second world
war with uh churchill is the main hero
uh hitler and stalin appearing on some
uh a few a few scenes
and millions of chinese that died in the
war never appearing at all
and you can do an entire world war two
movie
just about a single chinese village now
both are true and what do you choose is
not forced on you by
the reality it reflects very often
political and ideological and also
artistic
choices now when you go back to the
stone age
it's even more complicated because there
are so many things we just don't know i
mean
the the basic things we don't know what
family structure was like
you have all these discussions about
what is the natural human family and
lots of people believe well you know
it's obvious it's
a man a woman two and a half kids and a
dog this is a traditional family this
was always the case
but we know that even in recent history
this was not always the case it's not
the case today
in many countries close to 50 of
children don't grow up
in such a family today you go back to
the middle ages it's not
the structure of everybody you go to
biology to other apes
chimpanzees don't live like that
gorillas don't live like that orangutans
don't live like
like that so how did humans live 50 000
years ago
and the answer is we don't know we have
evidence from the stone age we have
tools but the tools don't tell you
what was the family structure uh you
have cave paintings
but one of the interesting things about
cave painting we've found
found thousands and thousands of cave
paintings from the stone age
there is not a single image of a family
there are a lot of mammoth there are
lots of horses there are lots of eye
backs
there are some humans also mostly stick
figures
but there isn't a single image from the
stone age
that you can say look that's how they
depicted a
family and what does it mean why do
people draw all these
elephants and never bother to draw their
own family i don't know what it means
but it's it's interesting
and it gives us as the uh you know a lot
of autistic freedom
about how to deal with these issues so
like i don't know we have this
uh one scene about neanderthals and you
know
neanderthals had a big revolution in the
last 10 years
of course they are dead but
our understanding of them has completely
changed in the last 10 years because of
so many new evidence we have both from
genetics
but also from artifacts and
archaeological records
and whereas 20 years ago maybe they were
still these archetypical
cave people primitive and brutal
and and things like that now they have a
very positive image
we have not only because we have their
genes in our dna
but also because we have evidence that
they took care of
of of wounded people of elderly people
of disabled people they had a much more
sophisticated
technology and maybe even art and
culture than
we assumed so we have we depicted in the
graphic novel
this change in image in this scene that
you see these two neanderthal guys
sitting in the office of a pr consultant
and the pr consultant has on the wall
this old-fashioned image of a
neanderthal a brutal neanderthal with a
big stick
dragging a female by by the hair and
there was a big x
over this image and the pr consultant
says well you know this was
a good brand for the 19th century but
this is a 21st century
you need to lighten up your brand and
the two neanderthals say yes well you
know actually we two are gay
so obviously we don't have any evidence
that they were
they were gay neanderthals i mean our
scientific understanding
of sex and gender today indicates that
it's very likely
that there were gay neanderthals but if
you ask for the smoking gun
show me a grave from 50 000
years ago with two men together only
then i believe
then of course we don't have this but
actually we hardly have
and we don't have a lot of direct
evidence for sex in the stone age we
have a lot of indirect evidence
like from genes so we know that sapiens
and neanderthals had sex
but maybe also the war cases of a
sapience men having sex with a
neanderthal men
could be no evidence in the genes of
course but
could it have happened maybe and uh
we have this autistic license that we
can show that it makes sense
well also i mean this is maybe going
down a rabbit hole but if you look at
the behavior of
of chimpanzees and others i mean there's
there's some evidence to suggest that
that type of interaction certainly
exists
yeah i mean if if you're looking at the
current day
precursors in a sense what is your hope
for these graphic novels and they're
coming out in four volumes
what do you anticipate or hope the
spacing to be of those
of those oh we hope for one every year
um
the main challenge is the drawing i mean
this is danielle's job
and i draw like a five-year-old kid i
mean they can't depend on me for
anything when it comes to the drawing
and it takes a lot of time to draw you
know these hundreds of
images and also it goes back and forth
because here daniel draws an image a
couple of images and send them
and then we go no the archaeological
evidence indicates that actually the
spear points were not like you depicted
and then i mean the the the political
issues that okay
we we need a more balanced gender
relations in this image and
and it goes back to daniel and he needs
to do to draw it again and it takes a
long time
so i guess it will be one volume each
year
and the big hope that it will reach new
audiences
that may not read you know a 400 page
text about the history of humankind but
would be interested and would find it
fun and engaging when it's sold in a
graphic novel i've seen the graphic
novel
and it's really well done i i have to
say you know i've
i've read i have probably 5 000 to 10
000 comic books
that i've saved and poly bagged over the
years
and i've collected everything from
sandman in the u.s
to dozens of different graphic novels in
japan
it's very well done so i mean yeah you
and your team deserve
a lot of credit for that i'd love to ask
a question
about your mission statement now i don't
know if you would call it a mission
statement maybe it is
so this is from the new yorker profile
from this year and it describes how your
mission statement reads as follows
and this is on a bulletin board in your
office
keep your eyes on the ball focus on the
main global problems facing humanity
learn to distinguish reality from
illusion care about suffering
and i guess there there was previously
embrace
ambiguity but that got scratched out yes
so
could you explain the origins of this
mission statement please oh it's a
couple of mission statements
you know as as we expand our team
it becomes more difficult to get
everybody on the same page to make sure
that everybody you know
each person has a different personal and
professional background
and so when it was just me or just my
husband and me there was no need to
write down these official mission
statements
but when you have 15 employees then it's
it becomes important
and we had a long discussion and uh like
a back and forth also with all the
employees and
we came up with these as several kind of
general guidelines
to to keep in mind and maybe the most
important thing is that we see
our task as helping to focus the global
conversation
on the most important issues
because one of the big problems of the
21st century is people are flooded by
enormous amounts of information
it's not like in the past when
information was scarce
and the problem was how to get it now
it's the opposite
and you just don't know what to pay
attention to and it also goes back to my
practice of meditation
of how to stay focused and
it's kind of link the personal practice
with the global project of again
we don't see ourselves as providing
solutions
but just kind helping to steer the
global conversation
in the most important directions
you have such a historical
context for determining
the relative weight to assign to
different
events or phenomena in the world
as indicated or described in the example
of terrorist attacks
and their sort of cultural or i
shouldn't say cultural but historic
significance like yes they're horrible
yes the theater and graphic nature of it
is very compelling to the human psyche
which would also be true of say a shark
attack right if a 12 year old boy were
attacked by a shark
on the east coast of the united states
it would be in every newspaper and there
would be a huge response
probably dramatic over harvesting of
sharks so on and so forth but in the
sweep of human history its importance is
is close to zero negligible what are
some of the more important the main
global problems facing humanity from
your perspective
well as we speak i think the three big
ones are nuclear war
which you know people tend to connect
with the cold war yeah there was
something there about nuclear weapons
but they were still here and i don't
think we'll see a nuclear war
in the next few months but if tensions
in the world continue to grow
then it will become again a major issue
and it is an existential issue
other things can't destroy us but
nuclear war can so we have to keep it in
mind all the time
the second big thing is ecological
collapse
it's not just climate change that gets
most of the headlines lately it's many
other things also
like loss of biodiversity and
destruction of habitats and so forth
but generally speaking yes we are seeing
uh we are in
where is nuclear war you know it's just
a future possibility
maybe it will happen maybe it won't
happen ecological collapse is already
began it's all around us
and it threatens again it's an
existential danger
it threatens the foundations of our
civilization
i guess that some people will survive it
but
if things really go bad with the
economic and political implications of
it
it could cost the lives of billions of
people
and the third big one and i think most
complicated
is technological disruption the
consequences of disruptive technologies
especially artificial intelligence
and bioengineering it's the most
complicated challenge
because you know with nuclear war and
climate change and ecological collapse
you can disagree whether it's true or
not but
everybody agrees what needs to be done
about it to stop it
nobody thinks that having a nuclear war
is a good idea nobody thinks that
climate change is a good idea maybe some
people deny it
but they don't say it's good now with
technological disruption
it's much much more complicated because
it has a lot of positive potential a lot
of people
positively wish to see greater and
faster
technological disruptions and there is
no agreement
whatsoever about what we should do with
technologies
like ai or like bioengineering the
dreams of some people are the nightmares
of other people so it's very complicated
again like like ecological collapse it's
not a future scenario it's already
happening all around us and i think the
pace is
such that it may to some people it
sounds like
crazy but i strongly believe that given
the technologies we are now developing
within a century or two at most our
species will disappear
the i don't think that in in the end of
the 21st 22nd century
the earth will still be dominated by
homo sapiens
i think given the immense powers of
technologies we are developing
there are two scenarios only one
scenario which is the
that the technology will destroy
humanity
and i think it's less likely but still
possible
the more likely scenario is that it will
change humanity in a profound way
that we will use ai and bioengineering
to change homo sapiens and to create new
kinds of beings
that will be much more different from us
than we are different from neanderthals
or from chimpanzees
to give just one example i think it is
possible that we will create the first
inorganic life forms after four billion
years of organic evolution
so again it's not a destruction of our
species
it's the changing of species into
something else
but what kind of thing it will be we
have to be extremely careful about that
it won't necessarily be a better version
of us
it could be much much worse could you
give
a bit more detail around the new
inorganic life form and in your mind's
eye
if we change for the worse in some tech
enabled way
deliberately or by accident what might
that look like to you
well i started with the second question
of what it could look like
you know you could use whatever
technology
to increase the
efficiency of people the intelligence of
people
at the price of things like autistic
sensitivity
or like spiritual depth i mean if you
ask armies if you ask corporations if
you ask governments
what do you need from your employees
from your soldiers
there was oh we want people to be more
efficient we want people to reach to be
more logical we want people to be
more disciplined and if you have the
technology then you engineer such people
even if it comes and it always comes i
mean usually when you improve something
it
tends to come at the price of something
else and things like i don't know
spiritual depth
what kind of army needs its soldiers to
have spiritual depth
so if you leave it to the corporations
and armies
it's very likely that once you have a
technology
to change humans it will i would say
downgrade them
and not upgrade them it will make them
more efficient soldiers or
employees or whatever but it will make
them kind of
poorer beings lesser beings so that's
about
just one scenario of what does it mean
to downgrade people
now with regard to inorganic life forms
you know for four billion years
everything
on the planet was all lifeforms were
organic
whether it's a bacteria or a mammoth or
a tree or a human it's organic it obeys
the laws of organic chemistry
now with the rise of a.i we might have a
chance
again i'm going to be agnostic about it
i'm not sure
but it is possible that in a couple of
decades
we will be able to create either
completely inorganic beings or
at least part organic part in organic
cyborgs
and this will be if it happens it will
be the biggest revolution in the history
of life since the beginning of life
much much bigger than the creation of
mammoth or the creation of mammals or
humans
because it's a completely different game
once you're no longer subject to organic
chemistry
we can't even begin to imagine what it
means
because our imagination is the product
of
organic chemistry so if you have a kind
of
intelligence which is not or based on
organic
chemistry you know it can be anything
if you look over the next so you're
talking about the i guess the the 22nd
century
and the prevalence dominance or
existence
of homo sapiens if we look over the next
50 years
just to choose an arbitrary time frame
of
nuclear war ecological collapse or
these unforeseen accidents or
mistakes of high technology
which scares you the most or which do
you worry about the most
i worry most about the third because of
what i said earlier that it's the most
complicated
that it's not enough to be kind of i
don't know good and wise
to deal with the first two it will be
very hard to deal with the first two as
it is
but the third one is really complicated
because there is no agreement on on the
goal
with the first two at least there is an
agreement on the goal
and and then that that makes it very
very complicated also you know the first
two
nobody is actively working
to make it happen sooner and even the
people who deny climate change
they are not in favor of climate change
they just say
it's not really doesn't happen but with
ai and bioengineering there are some of
the most powerful people
and organizations and governments and
corporations in the world
they are extremely busy making it happen
faster and it's also we don't have a
framework even to think about it
properly
so uh as a thinker and a politician i
think this is
where i can contribute the most is in
trying to entangle
this kind of completely new threat just
a few more questions then i'll
i'll let you get going because i know
we're separated by quite a few time
zones
when you are thinking about these
threats
perhaps hearkening back to your times
reading
aldous huxley's work and here we're
talking about brave new world and not
island right very different descriptions
although
some parallels when you feel
the potential for these various types of
collapse or disaster
what keeps you going where do you find
the light
it's a good question uh
you know if if you're able to deal with
your own mortality
as every person has to on some level
then you should be able to deal with the
potential mortality of your entire
species
i mean it's still part of biology as
individuals
come and go nations come and go also
entire species come and go
99 of the species that evolved on planet
earth are gone
for one reason or another homo sapiens
also is not internal
uh and even the best scenario i don't
think
homo sapiens will be around in two or
three hundred years
the best scenario is that homo sapiens
will disappear
but in a peaceful and gradual way and be
replaced by something better
i don't think there is any chance
whatsoever
that people like us will just continue
to have lives
like us in 200 years that they will be
in 200 years a professor of history sits
sitting and having a podcast
talk with somebody it's not going to
happen i mean
that the changes are going to be too big
so maybe it goes back again to the
practice of meditation and the
realization that uh
change is the only certainty in in life
so you might as well tune into the
changes so that you're at least aware
that you're responding to your reactions
to things outside and not the outside
itself well you've all this has been
a lot of fun for me i think it's nice to
connect with you
and of course i will link to everything
in the show notes for people
the volume one of
your series sapiens of graphic history
is out now volume one can be found
and i'll include links to that in
the show notes for everyone at tim dot
blog slash podcast your website is y
and harare uh facebook is
prof.uval.noaa.harari
twitter harare underscore uval instagram
you've all underscored noah underscore
ferrari and i'll
provide all of those so people don't
have to remember them is there anything
else that you would like
to say to my audience ask of the
audience suggest to the audience before
we wrap up
uh no just thank you for your time i
know that time and attention are the
most valuable resources
today for most people so i hope you
benefited from
investing them in listening to us
likewise
and i i can certainly speak for myself
and saying that i enjoyed it quite a lot
and definitely check out ted chang
exhalation i think i love it
i have a bunch of notes for things that
i will be checking out and
to everyone listening until next time
thank you
for tuning in hey guys this is tim again
just a few more things before you take
off
number one this is five bullet friday do
you want to get a short email from me
would you enjoy getting a short email
from me every friday
that provides a little morsel of fun
before the weekend
and five bullet friday is a very short
email where i share
the coolest things i've found or that
i've been pondering over the week
that could include favorite new albums
that i've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that i've somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as i do
it could include
favorite articles that i've read and
that i've shared with
my close friends for instance and it's
very short
it's just a little tiny bite of goodness
before you head off for the weekend so
if you want to receive that
check it out just go to four
hourworkweek.com that's
4hourworkweek.com all spelled out and
just drop in
your email and you will get the very
next one and if you sign up
i hope you enjoy it this episode is
brought to you by all form
if you've been listening to this podcast
for a while you've probably heard me
talk about helix
sleep and their mattresses which i've
been using since 2017. i have two of
them
upstairs from where i'm sitting at this
moment and now helix has gone beyond the
bedroom and started making
sofas they just launched a new company
called all form a-l-l-f-o-r-m and
they're making premium
customizable sofas and chairs shipped
right to your door at a fraction of the
cost of traditional stores
so i'm sitting in my living room right
now and it's entirely
all formed furniture i've got two chairs
i've got an ottoman and i have an
l sectional couch i'll come back to that
you can pick your fabric they're all
spill stained and scratch resistant the
soap
color the color of the legs the sofa
size the shape to make sure it's perfect
for you and your home
also all form arrives in just three to
seven days and you can assemble it all
yourself in a few minutes no tools
needed i was quite astonished by how
modular
and easy these things fit together kind
of like lego pieces they've got arm
chairs love seats all the way up to an
8c
sectional so there's something for
everyone you can also start small and
kind of build on top of it if you want
to get a smaller couch and then build
out on it which is actually in a way
what i did because i can turn
my l-sectional couch into a normal
straight couch and then with a separate
ottoman
in a matter of about 60 seconds it's
pretty rad so
i mentioned i have all these different
things in this room i use the natural
leg finish which is their lightest color
and i dig it and i've been using these
things hours and hours and hours
every single day so i am using
what i am sharing with you guys and if
getting a sofa without trying it in
store sounds risky
you don't need to worry all form sofas
are delivered directly to your home with
fast free shipping and you get 100 days
to decide if you want to keep it
that's more than three months and if you
don't love it they'll pick it up for
free and give you a full refund
your sofa frame also has a forever
warranty that's literally
forever so check it out take a look
they've got all sorts of cool stuff
to choose from i was skeptical and it
actually worked it worked much better
than i could have
imagined and i'm very very happy so to
find your perfect sofa check out
allform.com
tim that's a-l-l-f-o-r-m.com
tim all form is offering 20 off all
orders to you my dear listeners at
allform.com
tim make sure to use the code tim at
checkout
that's allforum.com tim and use code tim
at checkout this episode is brought to
you by
peak tea that's p-i-q-u-e i have
had so much tea in my life i've been to
china i've lived in china
in japan i've done tea tours i drink a
lot of tea
and 10 years plus of physical
experimentation and tracking has shown
me many things
chief among them that gut health is
critical to just about everything and
you'll see where
tea is going to tie into this it affects
immune function weight management mental
performance emotional health you name it
i've been drinking fermented poo air tea
specifically
pretty much every day for years now poo
air tea delivers more polyphenols and
probiotics than you can shake a stick at
it's like providing the optimal
fertilizer to your microbiome
the problem with good poo air is that
it's hard to source it's hard to find
real poorer that hasn't been exposed to
pesticides and other nasties which is
super common that's why
peaks fermented poo air tea crystals
have become my daily
go-to it's so simple they have so many
benefits that i'm going to get into and
i first learned about them
through my friends dr peter atia and
kevin rose peak crystals
are cold extracted using only wild
harvested leaves from 250 year old tea
trees
i often kick start my mornings with
their poor green tea their poor black
tea
and i alternate between the two the rich
earthy flavor of the
black specifically is amazing it's very
very it's like a
a delicious barnyard very peaty if you
like whiskey and stuff like that
they triple toxin screen all of their
products for heavy metals pesticides and
toxic molds contaminants commonly found
in tea
there's also zero prep or brewing
required
as the crystals dissolve in seconds so
you can just drop it into your hot tea
or i also make iced tea and that saves a
ton of time and hassle
so peek is offering 15 off their
priorities for the very first time
exclusive to you my listeners this is a
sweet offer
simply visit peakt.com tim that's
p-i-q-u-e-t-e-a
dot com forward slash tim this promotion
is only available
to listeners of this podcast that's peak
t
dot com forward slash tim the discount
is automatically applied when you use
that url
you also have a 30 day satisfaction
guarantee so your purchase is
risk free one more time check it out
peak t that's p i q
e t e a dot com slash time
[Applause]